Officials on high alert
at the US-Mexico border.
The Biden administration is send
more agents
to El
Paso, Texas, over concerns
about the recent migrant surge t
This as a Trump era
policy called
Title 42 is set to expire
a week from today.
19 GOP led states are asking
a federal appeals court
to keep Title 42 in place,
which allowed the U.S.
to quickly
expel asylum seekers at the bord
El Paso's city manager
saying they are at a breaking po
title 42.
Going away with the numbers
we're seeing today
is a
is a true emergency for the comm
It's a federal crisis
that's happening within the
in the border of El Paso.
So let's go straight
to CNN's Ed Lavandera
live for us at the El Paso
in El Paso, Texas, I should say.
Ed, good morning to you.
You have been on the ground in E
What are you seeing there?
Well, you
know, as
the city
manager there alluded
to, there's a great deal of conc
about what is going to happen ne
if Title 42 is officially lifted
Right now,
over the last few days,
what we have
seen is about an average of 2500
migrants crossing the border
into the El Paso area.
This is separate
from the issue of Title 42.
And what we are hearing from off
here in El Paso is that
shelters are overcapacity
of the processing centers
with a border patrol
are also overcapacity as well.
So that is raising
a great deal of concern about
what is going to happen next wee
And city officials
here are sounding the alarm
What what we need to do here,
I think, is much more than than
what we're doing at this point.
We need people to step up.
We need to stop pointing fingers
We need to work together.
We need to collaborate.
And we need to
to make sure that we keep
folks that are
passing through our neighborhood
our neighborhoods, safe,
also keeping our
communities safe as well.
And, Don, the Biden
administration is predicting tha
if Title 42 is lifted,
there could be as many as nine
to 14,000 people crossing the U.
southern border next week.
That is what they are preparing
Officials in the DHS officials
said yesterday
they are sending more agents her
and as well as a thousand
processing officers,
that will help
handle the number of people
that are coming across the borde
But there is a growing sense of
about what is going to unfold he
next week Don.
Ed, where exactly
are these migrants looking to go
and where would they go
after being deported?
You know, it's interesting.
We were in a shelter last night.
And so there are a number of peo
because of Title 42
who are being expelled
immediately returned.
You know, back to Mexico.
But there are people
who are given processing papers
dates, immigration
court dates
to appear in several months from
We spoke with a number of people
who have been traveling
to or planning to travel to plac
like Georgia, Pennsylvania, New
So they're actually spending
very little time
here in border communities
moving on to other destinations
where they might already
have family members or, you know
friends who have already set up
or establish some sort of routes
So that's what we're hearing a l
from the migrants that we've spo
Ed Lavendera
in El Paso, Texas, for us this m
Thank you, Caitlin.
All right.
A bipartisan group of lawmakers
the subject is now urging Presid
Biden to extend Title 42.
They warn that lifting
it next week will result in a co
loss of operational control.
Over the southern border.
And they believe
it will have a profoundly negati
on these border communities.
One of the lawmakers
who represents
those communities is Texas Congr
Henry Cuellar.
He represents a southwest border
district and joins us now.
Congressman,
it's title 42 and is scheduled.
How much more difficult
does managing the migrant crisis
Do you believe
communities are going to be over
Not only in Paso?
We've seen that in the past
with Rio Grande
Valley we've seen in Eagle Pass
They're going to be overwhelmed.
They just not enough
shelters and border processing c
to handle
the large numbers of people
and what Border Patrol is doing.
It's almost like
Whac-A-Mole in this, in the sens
that if there's a surge in the v
they'll move people down there.
There's
if there's more people crossing
during the,
let's say,
the real Eagle Pass
and move agents over there,
now they're moving agents to El
So it's really
this is not the way to secure th
Look, we can do two things
at the same time.
We can provide a compassionate
a way of treating the
the immigrants are trying to com
But at the same time,
we have to secure the border
because the only thing
that the Border Patrol is doing
is processing
a lot of them to come into the U
And then returning
some of them
under Title 42,042 goes away.
This is going to just open up a
of large numbers of people
coming to border communities.
And do you think the Biden admin
understands that sense of urgenc
You know, I
don't think they do or they do.
They just have
a very different perspective.
Look, it's
okay to listen to immigration ac
It's okay to do that.
That's one perspective
But who's listening to the men a
in green and blue
and more importantly,
who's listening
to our border communities?
I live in Laredo, Texas.
I live in the border
And and again,
I don't just go visit there.
I know.
And I talk to the mayors,
our county judges, commissioners
landowners, other folks there.
And nobody's listening
or should I say
the administration
is not listening to them.
You know, it's
it's about time
that they pay attention
to border communities.
Would it help
if they placed
new limits on asylum seekers?
Well, it's
not a matter of putting limits o
asylum seekers.
It's how you process
those asylum seekers locally.
If you put
100 people in front of an immigr
judge and by the way,
the immigration courts are overw
There's about a backlog
of 1.9 million cases.
That's years.
Years in the future
before
they can really have their day i
But but what we're looking at is
if you put 100 people
in front of an immigration judge
88 to 90% are going to be reject
So why are we not doing this?
Why are we not saying that
there's an asylum seeker
coming in from another country
and they pass a third country?
And I've been talking about this
for about four
or five years
where they can seek
asylum somewhere else.
Why is the US
the only place
that they can get away from pers
There's a lot of countries
on the way over here
that they can ask for that,
or if they can do it in an
orderly process,
ask for asylum
in one of our consulates
or embassies abroad,
they say it's got to be orderly.
What you see in El Paso,
what you saw in Eagle Pass
or Rio, what you seen in the val
I don't call that orderly.
And I don't understand
why the administration
doesn't understand that.
I want to be constructive.
I want to work with them to addr
this issue.
And Congressman,
you saw DHS secretary,
my orcas at the border.
Do you think it would help
if President Biden himself
came to El Paso,
came to the border to see this f
look?
Yes, absolutely.
I think I don't know why
they keep avoiding the border
and say there's other things
more important
than visiting their border.
If there's a crisis show up,
just show up.
I think part of
the battle is
if he shows up and says
that we'll be working on this
and on this just showing up at t
would send a strong signal
to the communities
that he's there,
he cares about the border commun
just show up.
It doesn't take much
to just show up at the border.
And Congressman,
while we have you this morning,
before we let you go,
Sam Bankman-fried,
as you've seen, has been indicte
on several
criminal charges
it's raising questions
about the political donations he
I believe he's donated to you.
Please correct me if I'm wrong.
Can you tell me?
I think you're incorrect on that
I think you're not correct.
As far as I know,
they have not donated to me.
I don't know who the person is.
I'm so glad you cleared that up
because we've been looking
at the donations he's made.
Public is reported
that he had donated to you.
Do you want to see fellow Democr
and Republicans that he donated
to all return those donations
or donate them to charities
like we've seen some do
Yes.
I think they should return it to
All right, Congressman,
thank you so much on two
very important topics this morni
Thanks for joining us.
Thank you so much.